Tim wasn't doing so well he's been
struggling so we sent him off to a farm
where he's going to run around with all
of the other beanied journalists all day
long and he's gonna have a great time so
well you know Tim's been getting a
little older and he's not able to
skateboard as much as he liked so as
easily yes we just want him to be around
people who can help him and take care of
him yeah it was like a
like a farm where people take he's like
on a farm with other Farmers no he's on
a farm with other journalists and
they're all running around and having a
fun time wearing their are they writing
articles uh yeah absolutely yeah if they
want to they can but I think they're
having so much fun skateboarding oh yeah
and sometimes when you go to a fun Farm
yeah he may want to stay there for a
minute what longer than a week uh you
know I we just wanna
we don't want to promise anything right
now buddy knock what kind of farm
we'll we'll probably get into it in a
bit but he's okay
we don't want you to worry well thanks
yeah I'm worried